two of the oldest universities in the
United States Harvard and the University
of North Carolina have used race as one
of the many factors to admit potential
qualified students
but a group of Asian American students
sued UNC and Harvard claiming the
practice denied them access to an Elite
Education in favor of lesser-qualified
African-American and Latino applicants
on Thursday the U.S Supreme Court agreed
ruling six to three that using race as a
factor violated the 14th Amendment to
the Constitution and the 1964 Civil
Rights Act
while opposing groups of students
reacted to the ruling on the court steps
The Man Behind the student's lawsuits
celebrated these obligations compel
the removal of all racial and ethnic
classification boxes from undergraduate
and postgraduate application forms the
incoming president of Harvard said the
school is now reworking the way it
admits new students while still focusing
on diversity we will comply with the
Court's decision but it does not change
our values the U.S president blasted the
decision and called the Supreme Court an
obstacle to social progress that is it's
done more to unravel basic rights and
basic decisions than any Court in
Regency recent history take a look at
how it's uh how it's ruled on a number
of issues that are have been precedent
for 50 60 years sometimes the White
House is providing legal advice and
other support to help schools comply
with the ruling the reaction from
Harvard students sadness and anger I'm
infuriated and speechless
um
this is just racism it's just racism
with a very thin veil I've just met so
many people from so many different
backgrounds and like it will just break
my heart for people in the future to
lose that Harvard and the University of
North Carolina had argued that they were
using race as an admissions factor in
order to create a student body that
would be more sensitive to the diversity
of the United States and thus create a
generation of Future Leaders that would
thus be more responsive to the
challenges in the years ahead the
Supreme Court said that's a laudable
goal but it's not enough to justify
violating the U.S Constitution
Russell and Jordan Al Jazeera the
Supreme Court
State legis